the gallon dress
my name is cream on the back welcome
back to another episode of happy wheels
have you brothers been waiting for this
I mean escaped and we get to play us
alright son come to me son whoa Wow was
that are we in the matrix hey why are
you here
I don't know guards back up odd sack my
daddy okay yes I eat access all the time
it's totally fine
actually plays dad please say something
I am talking oh this is my chance
Oh smack that stop dog give me some more
stop singing
yeah I'm sorry I don't know I already
play that map but I guess since I don't
even remember playing it I guess we can
try it again
I don't care by the gods son of a [ __ ]
ah no it's my time to shine how do I get
past the [ __ ] guards alright alright
back off no not us eat your leg it's a
son of a [ __ ] right in my you're stuck
to me you little [ __ ]
son I'm kicking you that's what you get
for whoa whoa son of a-- thou is not
whoa well my legs okay
thanks for delivering them back you're
most kind alright let's try this down
back off your little shits there we go
[ __ ] guards ma'am
alright hello it was like ah how the
hell am I supposed to go back for all
right dad just be swift like Taylor
Swift every no bad girl
all right we've [ __ ] made it was that
door Oh oh my arm fell off I was not a
shame I slap you son
no buy on fella everybody now say eh
okay let's go up here no problem at all
daddy okay yes I always wanted to be a
freak without an arm oh okay whoa
here step I nearly stepped in that [ __ ]
all right
that's why are you so angry you are not
passing [ __ ] are you Gandalf
hah you think you're Gandalf this is
what I do - Gandalf penis watch hey that
was awesome dad I just be quiet
jump whoa whoa whoa whoa there we go
there we go
I pooped a little no give me the child
be happy to give that [ __ ] to you whoa
whoa whoa why is your head stuck there
oh you took my helmet
all right go side of a [ __ ] I died
anyway
you killed the kidnapper he would be
doing me a favor
I would actually pay him to kidnap my
[ __ ] all right let's try strop swing
200 okay I can never get them the first
[ __ ] time I don't know what I do
wrong I'm fabulous rainbows come on
there we go
grab that [ __ ] come on I can't grab it
in my faith no cheating that's supposed
to mean
why would I need to cheat son okay I
probably need to cheat all right let it
go ah it's difficult come on baby girl
you left me
why is your feet going past you stupid
son of a penis there we go
that's not what I wanted at all all
right now let's go why do why do you do
this to me senorita yes yes yes
cannonball yes yes I made it
I like this Oh what the hell is going on
here
stop tickling me that I was tickling
whoa I like it okay keep going far away
yes yes [ __ ] awesome
now it's not so bad hardest spike game
that sounds like a porno alright let's
play with these little [ __ ] game a
myspace batch can't go what can you say
so annoying oh I can't fit you're too
fat
take away still my mom
alright let's go oh oh ah I want to try
that it was irresponsible that dad -
please I don't like it oh why did they
make us choose a character if you can
only fed it boy I'm so stupid I was
trying to click that there you are hey
there we go
no problem this is gonna go splendid nah
ha oh oh whoa I can make it no so close
segue no leave me are you my dad what
why does it say that all right let's do
this ah [ __ ] I came to come on like my
penis is huge holy [ __ ] but why should I
let's go with him and up the other
characters it lets out [ __ ] like how
it's done my bike will do it [ __ ] why
did you say a little [ __ ] don't swear in
my presence sorry dad I'll show you how
it's done you little [ __ ]
alright cuz I'm free
no not the legs
side of Ahaz [ __ ] god dammit I'm sorry
that I tried is never good enough in
this family and it's kind of difficult
but I want to try it
alright the third the [ __ ] best bug I
Segway guy whatever your name is
there we go it's perfect it's perfect
it's perfect
perfect come up I'm sorry I don't
alright son dad be careful I heard this
map just goes on for eternity ah doesn't
matter in this family just be quiet
whoa whoa whoa whoa it's going to pass
gets going super duper uber uber fast
holy [ __ ] we're going in the speed of
light right now
Oh ain't got no arms ain't got no care
ain't got no I like the amount of
carriage holla shed this is not good for
anyone speed it's all your fault you
little [ __ ] I hate you don't get away
from me you're [ __ ] disturbing
awesome
alright let's try this again you little
[ __ ] if you last long in the dark how am
I supposed to count 30 seconds speed of
light [ __ ]
everybody in the house eh [ __ ] my head
go son go you can dodge I believe in ya
oh you disgrace you describes for all go
bike career what the hell is going on in
this picture whoa
well bike I thought you were my team
holy [ __ ] what's going on here
Oh what well speed of light whoa am I
still alive I don't think you're
technically I'm still alive kill your
boss television track that sounds fun
let's try that
whoa a television track I'm always my
dream finally comes to backup vicious I
have a television
track back out hey I love this [ __ ] look
at this it's no use
oh yes it is oh no I can't my father
whoa
television track go back on your feet
television track turn back there we go
whoa whoa whoa please don't so sorry
please bullet
[ __ ] that [ __ ] oh don't care don't care
about anything
fantastic it was really fun
skyscrapers suicide that not a mat all
right then dad
thanks I want to be with you forever
watch it
Oh enough to chicken anything budget
check-in side of a Santa what the hell
were they doing up there shut up a [ __ ]
don't striding my pressures I keep
telling you god damn it all right son
just to try it out you go first
whoa whoa that's me aah get away from me
you sick [ __ ] oh all right I'm out of
here
sayonara [ __ ] oh oh whoa
Santa Claus what are you doing with a
shotgun you little [ __ ] get off me oh
right in this [ __ ] whoa got no arms
it's okay that's okay I guess I gotta go
after him [ __ ] forward holy [ __ ] you're
so slow you little [ __ ] dad I'm trying
the hardest I can all right let's go
whoa whoa like that
I'm sorry - I don't really make it uh
that's always happy real Massacre isn't
that fantastic abs ed what is this a
plus though
whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa us oh so sorry
for your legs
actually it's my arm what do I do now
can I control this left key backwards I
don't think I did it alright let's try
it again
pressing up for less then right key what
aa ton of them
oh whoa this is - possum and spinning
and it's outside about the auto kissing
come on big stop not my fault
they told me I could become anything and
I wanted to become a spinning thing in
the air shooting shakkoumon alright
let's try this again I don't care ah ye
slide what come here son
what I'm not here are you my mom are you
are you my love you I why did you adopt
me I don't get it so many questions
right now
why is my leg our mom now not backward
mom I love you mom mom pop god dammit
do you versus hater don't move no no no
I don't like don't move mess how wait we
can try it I guess
Wow how'd I shed my leg but wide bounce
from top deposit so freaking hot yeah
yeah bounce that [ __ ] oh no not her
pillows anything buddy hey Rania let us
[ __ ] all right there we go banking or
whatever you suck well that's okay
thanks what but had my argument
major leakage in my all right that's
okay back in the Cannonball I guess
alright son of a [ __ ] don't show me
whatever y'all know I don't care okay
alright I'm in a rocket now with no
limbs stumpy what the hell does that
mean ah gotta get balled up got shot
again out of space oh that means face me
I'm catch what are you doing Oh wrecking
ball I'm in a helicopter now Santa Claus
how you doing alright let's continue our
[Laughter]
hospital all right
and we donated a heart to a hobo and we
spit it out I guess
oh no don't let him go down there no no
no homie don't hover
ah how about why do you do this I'm
gonna get so much crap for this alright
that was pretty much it hope you enjoyed
happy wheels like a favorite if you
enjoyed subscribe to come abroad today
and I'll see you next after toda I me
haha that was not a voice crack that was
I don't know okay you can't Doug judge
be alright
[Music]
oh no that little clown [ __ ]